they said we have something called The
Tall poppy syndrome that when one poppy
grows up higher than the others somebody
comes along and cuts that off
do you think you know you talked about
going to the film School in Denmark or
working with the Danish students certain
cultures have less of a return with the
Elixir at the end just as as in life
that doesn't always happen oh I'm glad
to talk about the differences from
culture to culture because this really
just came up and hit me like I'd stepped
on a rake or something
when I first started traveling I found
that I was carrying with me a bag of
cultural assumptions that came from
growing up in the midwest
I lived on a farm most of my childhood
and my diet was entirely Old Warner
Brothers movies and cartoons and what
was on television then so Superman and
Zorro and things like that
and there were a lot of cultural
assumptions embedded in that like the
hero is a good Force the hero can change
things the hero can save us uh the hero
uh usually is unselfish and uh is has
the best interests of society in mind
and as soon as I got out of the frame of
the United States of America I started
meeting all these other ideas that uh
for instance in Eastern Europe they
would say to me
um yeah you mentioned these characters
who think they can change the world and
who think one person can make a
difference we actually have some of
those but we don't call them Heroes we
call them fools and idiots because
nobody can really change the world it
just is how it is and
um you know you're foolish if you think
you can you can mark the system
so I began to understand that I needed
to broaden my ideas and some cultures
were just outright uh disapproving of
the term hero and I've noticed that some
people like the screenwriting teacher in
Denmark had
clipped out the word hero and he just he
didn't teach the hero's journey he
taught the journey
and I think that was actually a wise
move because it does away with a lot of
cultural baggage that we have about
heroes uh you know when I first started
teaching about it uh people assumed oh
you're talking about male Heroes because
when we say hero we usually mean a male
hero and I said no no no that's that's
not the way I mean it it could be any
gender it couldn't even be genderless
being animal or uh you know spirit
so don't get hung up on on gender or uh
you know their natural equipment but
um
I I began to see that I needed to
broaden my view of things and so
different cultures have different
emphasis uh we in the west tend to
gravitate towards stories that have a
single hero or at most what they call
the two-hander where there will be two
people like it my buddy type story or
romance where the two are kind of
balanced equally but a lot of cultures
don't acknowledge stories like that at
all and they only think a story is
something about a whole Community or a
group or a family and
um so I I've had to do some editing of
my thoughts and try to to get closer to
a world view rather than my own cultural
view it still has value and it certainly
translates uh around the world everybody
kind of gets the Hollywood model and
they copied a lot of places but it's
very healthy that they reject it in some
ways and have their own standards and
and Views about that and I'm fine with
that sure because I think In some
cultures it's considered a bad thing to
stand out what is it the the nail that
is the highest gets hammered down
there's different uh sayings so yeah but
in ours we're seduced by the the
individual who takes the reins and
Against All Odds and Rises up against
the crowd so that's right we hold it up
as some high value that somebody uh puts
their hand up they volunteer they stick
out of the crowd uh they're you know
rugged individuals or something like
that but as you say in other cultures uh
the base assumption is no we're all the
same here mate as they told me in
Australia they said we have something
called The Tall poppy syndrome that when
one poppy grows up higher than the
others somebody comes along and cuts
that off so you better keep your head
down and and you know not stand out or
not claim to be higher or better than
everybody else and I think this is a
real difference
in cultures that the Western culture
American movie culture is generally
pretty aspirational it's it's aiming for
or striving for greater achievement more
risk greater reward
um sort of selling that idea that uh you
know you don't you don't get without you
give some risk and so uh that's not
believed in every culture and and that
has to be taken into account
I don't know this this may get I'm not
trying to go political here but in in
American films too the the individual
takes on the the corporation the
government whereas maybe in some
countries that could be a death sentence
they wouldn't make it and so uh just the
the risk of of how we may appear
um
to Brash or I'm foolish I don't know
where I'm going with this but yeah I
think that there's a tendency
um in Western culture and Hollywood
movie making to think that unless the
story involves somebody who steps up and
who does the extraordinary thing who
takes the great risk uh then that's a
story not worth telling and I have just
seen a documentary I'm sorry I can't
remember the name of it but it had
something to do with people
who were running bird rescues in India
and they had this certain kind of bird
of prey called a it's a scavenger really
called a kite and the kites were just
dropping out of the sky because of
pollution and so these two men brothers
had decided that that was their mission
in life was to rescue these birds and
give decent burial to the ones who died
and nurse the other ones along
and the end of the story was actually
quite hopeless and it painted this uh
sad picture of uh a world where their
little efforts were not making any
difference at all uh
and and the forces of the world were
converging more and more so that there
would be less and less of these birds
and uh more problems uh but there was
something although is very sad there was
something Noble about it the fact that
they were trying anyway uh and so it was
a a challenging thing to me from my
Western perspective because I kept
hoping that they would have a
breakthrough or that they'd get a
government grant or that they'd somehow
you know turn around
this pollution situation but they they
didn't give me that and uh that was okay
because I uh felt something
that I don't normally feel which is this
sense of Despair that there are certain
things going on in the world we can't do
anything about
um but isn't it wonderful when somebody
tries so you got a little bit of both
views with that one and I think that's
the balance we look for
um you know a totally Grim outlook on on
life is hard that's hard to watch for
anybody in any culture but um
the balance is what I think is healthy